Here's a grisly fact: Britain's first serial
killer wasn't Jack the Ripper, but a Victorian-era
woman named Mary Ann Cotton who was hanged
in 1873 for murdering three husbands and 15 children.
[MUSIC]
Hi, I'm Cristen Conger of Stuff Mom Never
Told You in today for DNews.
Fortunately, murder is a rare crime, but when
it happens, the perpetrator is usually male.
According to the U.S. Justice Department,
for instance, roughly 9 out of 10 homicides
are committed by men. And similarly, from
2002 to 2012, 93.9% of people convicted of
murder in England and Wales were men.
So what provokes women like Mary Ann Cotton
and triple-murderer Joanna Dennehy, whose
gruesome crimes have recently captured British
attention?
Criminologists have identified certain differences
in how women murder, compared to men:
Women tend to murder people they know, for
instance: According to U.S. data collected
between 1976 and 2005, about 42 percent female
murderers' victims were intimate partners
or other family members.
Perhaps because of that, women are less likely
to kill more than once, and since 2000 women
have comprised only around 6 percent of serial
killers.
And finally, women use poison or arson more
commonly, rather than wielding a weapon that
might demand more physical strength to claim
victims' lives.
But as for the whys of women killing, it involves
a range of motives such as greed, jealousy
and psychopathy, just as they do with men
who murder.
Speaking to the BBC, clinical psychologist
Elie Godsi also noted that the public might
seek out a specific explanation for why women
murder since the crime is such a violent violation
of female gender norms.
We tend to think of women as society's nurturers
and caregivers -- not bloodthirsty killers.
Now we want to hear from you -- why do you
think murderous women are so attention-grabbing?
Comment below and tweet us @DNews.